thank you very much so nice to be with
you America continues to gain ground in
the war against the virus I want to
thank the American people for answering
the call following our guidelines and
making these sacrifices required to
overcome this terrible threat more
aggressively we commit to social
distancing so important social
distancing such an important phrase and
we do it right now the more lives that
we can save and the sooner we can
eventually get people back to work back
to school and back to normal and there
are large sections of our country
probably can go back much sooner than
other sections and we're obviously
looking at that also people who are
asking is that an alternative I say
absolutely it is an alternative I have
now approved major disaster declarations
for New York California Washington Iowa
Louisiana Texas and Florida that has
great significance as you know and legal
significance we're in a constant
grouping and I can say this we have a
large grouping of people that does
nothing but communicate with the various
officials including we've been spending
a lot of time with New York officials
because that really is by far the
hottest spot they've got a number of
very tough weeks ahead of them
the governor's doing a very good job I
spoke to the governor Governor Cuomo
last night and this morning and he
mentioned that in his remarks that he's
using the that we are using and I think
he feels because he understands
negotiation he thinks we're using very
appropriately the defense but
act and we are we're using it where
needed it's a great point of leverage
it's a great negotiating tool but I've
really I will tell you this tremendous
spirit from people and tremendous spirit
with respect to these companies and I
don't have to use it very much at all
they want to do it as you know General
Motors is involved Ford's involved 3m is
involved others are involved and they're
all working very hard to produce product
different all different products we had
very little product when we came we
built it up and we've we give it away as
fast as we can to the different states
we're also as you know building numerous
hospitals and medical centers throughout
certain areas in New York it's at the
convention center the Javits Convention
Center we're doing for hospitals and
we're doing throughout the state for
medical centers they're somewhat
different I want you to know that I'm
doing everything in my power to help the
city pull through this challenge I'm
working very hard in New York it's
really by far our biggest problem maybe
it will be maybe it won't be but there's
a lot of good capable people working on
it with us and our teams are working
very well with the state representatives
we're also doing some very large
testings throughout the country I told
you yesterday that in South Korea this
is not a knock in any way because I've I
just spoke with president moon we had a
very good conversation about numerous
other things but they've done a very
good job in testing but we now are doing
more testing than anybody by far we do
more in eight days and they do in eight
weeks and we go up on a daily basis
exponentially so it's really good by the
way while I'm on it I'd also spoke with
Prime Minister Robby of Japan last night
and I congratulated him on a wise choice
I think it's going to be a fantastic
Olympics 2021 I think it's going to be a
fantastic
Olympics it was the absolute right
decision to delay it for a full year and
now have a full beautiful Olympics it's
going to be very important because it's
probably the first time maybe ever or
certainly in a long time that it was on
a odd year so he's on an even year they
tell me but he's gonna have a fantastic
success and now that I've even more time
he didn't need any more time everything
was perfectly ready what a job they've
done but Japan and I want to
congratulate Japan the IOC and Prime
Minister ah beyond a great decision I
think it's going to be a fantastic
Olympics I told them I'll be there I'll
be there as we fight to protect American
lives we're also protecting American
livelihoods Democrats and Republicans in
the Senate are very close to passing an
emergency relief bill for American
workers families and businesses this
legislation in addition to the two bills
I signed this month that includes as you
know sick leave and we have all sorts of
things and for the workers for families
but we have a tremendous paid sick leave
provision for workers at no cost at all
to the employers and that's a big thing
no cost to the employers we want to get
everybody back working together this 2.2
trillion dollar legislative package is
bigger than anything I believe ever
passed in Congress perhaps relatively
speaking if you go back look during the
FDR New Deal days there was something
that if you time value it you could say
it was bigger I don't know but this is
certainly in terms of dollars by far and
away the biggest ever ever done and
that's a tremendous thing because a lot
of this money goes to jobs jobs jobs and
families families families the Senate
bill as you know includes three hundred
and fifty billion dollars in job
retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available
for businesses that continue paying
their workers they continue paying their
workers that's what we want we want them
to keep their workers and pay their
workers this well businesses keep
workers in the payroll that allow our
economy to quickly accelerate as soon as
we defeat the virus 300 billion dollars
in direct cash payments will be
available for every American citizen
earning less than 99 thousand dollars
per year that would be three thousand
four hundred dollars very quickly for
the typical family of four nothing like
that's ever been done in our country up
to two hundred and fifty billion dollars
in expanded unemployment benefits the
average worker who has lost his or her
job will receive 100% of their salary
for up to four full months
unlike normal unemployment benefits
independent contractors and the
self-employed will be eligible so you
have independent contractors and
self-employed people will be eligible
for this over 100 billion dollars to
support the heroic work of our doctors
nurses and hospitals they've been
incredible forty five billion dollars
for disaster relief fund so we are
setting up a fund to forty five billion
dollars for disaster relief that's more
than doubling the amount available to
support my national emergency and
disaster declarations
it's a doubling up twenty seven billion
dollars to build up the strategic
national stockpile with critical
supplies including masks respirators
pharmaceuticals and everything you can
imagine because it was very depleted
like our military was depleted now we
have a brand new military and have had a
military like this we have equipment
either coming or it's already come for
the most part it's already come but we
have a lot of things that will soon be
coming planes missiles rockets lots of
things but the stockpile was very
depleted like everything else this will
also include significant funding for the
development of vaccines on top of the
eight billion dollars we
approved several weeks ago over five
hundred billion dollars in support for
the hardest-hit industries with a ban on
corporate stock buybacks which is
something I insisted on and frankly I
tell you the Republicans wanted that and
the Democrats wanted that we want him to
use the money for the companies and the
planes or whatever they may be helping
to get over this rough patch and I don't
think it's gonna end up being such a
rough patch I think it's gonna when we
open especially if we can open it the
sooner the better it's going to open up
like a rocket ship I think it's going to
go very good and very quickly and you
can have some tough new limits on
executive compensation also they need
the money they're gonna have to sort of
just make things work because we're
interested in the workers the jobs and
we're interested in the companies
because that's really what what fuels
the workers in those great jobs and we
also have 16 billion dollars in funding
for the purchase of personal protective
equipment you know about that such as
masks and respirators through the
strategic national stockpile I encourage
the house to pass this vital legislation
and send the bill to my desk for
signature without delay I will sign it
immediately we will have a signing and
it'll be a great signing and a great day
for the American worker and for American
families and frankly for American
companies some of which were having the
best years they've ever had his last few
years and then a little bit less than a
month ago they went into a position that
they haven't seen because of the hidden
enemy the virus earlier today I spoke to
the leaders of many of America's amazing
nonprofit organizations I thank them for
their unwavering and unwavering devotion
to American people to American families
to our nation and they have been
fantastic they've been collecting
supplies distributing food
courting healthcare workers caring for
vulnerable workers and families I
encourage them to continue to do it but
I'll tell the nonprofit's have been
fantastic they've been great they're
great people actually I know a lot of
them finally I want to provide a brief
update on the critical supplies through
FEMA the federal government is delivered
or is in the process of shipping nine
point four million n95 respirators think
of that nine point four million twenty
million
surgical masks and we have others that
we think are going to be delivered
pretty quickly the whole world you know
it's not just us it's not just the
states the whole world is trying to get
these things so come in competition with
many many countries I believe today you
broke the hundred and fifty mark for the
virus we have a hundred and fifty
countries over a hundred and fifty
countries where you have this virus and
nobody would ever believe a thing like
that's possible nobody could have ever
seen something like this coming but now
we know when we know it can happen and
happen again and if it does somebody's
going to be very well prepared because
of what we've learned and how we've done
it's been incredible how we've done
remember there's more tests than anybody
by far and the news the reporters the
media it was likes to bring South Korea
they called me and they told me it's
amazing you're testing procedures are
amazing plus we have a test that's a
very high-level test and it's a test
that's very accurate 3.1 million facials
2.6 million surgical gowns 14.6 million
gloves and almost six thousand
ventilators which go to the areas of
greatest needs we sent over the last day
four thousand ventilators to New York
and I spoke with the governor about that
he was happy I spoke with the mayor also
about that mara DeBlasio he was very
happy it's hard not to be happy with his
job we're doing that I can tell you
throughout this national emergency every
day heroes continue to step forward and
demonstrate the extraordinary character
of
nation including the people behind me by
the way these people are amazing they
are amazing people and they become I
don't know maybe I should just speak for
myself but to me they'd become friends
maybe they don't like me maybe they
don't maybe they do I don't know all I
can tell you is if they're talented
people they work very hard in Maryland a
seven-year-old boy used his own birthday
money to buy meals for dozens of senior
citizens in Nevada a college student
recruited 90 of her friends to help
deliver groceries and supplies to the
most vulnerable this is happening all
over the country thousands and thousands
of instances I could stand up here all
day and tell you about other things in
Minnesota hundreds of medical students
have volunteered to provide child care
for hospital workers helping to keep our
doctors and nurses on the front lines
fighting to save lives these inspiring
Americans remind us that we all have a
role to play in winning this great
national battle and it's really a
worldwide battle we're dealing with
other nations all the time the people
here are I am a little bit
I take calls from a lot of people
they're in trouble a lot of countries
are in big trouble so now we will hear
from our great Secretary of the Treasury
he's been working rather hard I will
tell you Steve malucci's is a fantastic
guy and he loves our country and he's
been dealing with both sides Republican
and Democrats he sort of lived over in
that beautiful building it's a very
beautiful building to me one of the most
beautiful buildings actually in the
world that he's gotten to know it Steve
very well so if we could have a little
update state would be fantastic as to
how we're doing and what it's looking
like thank you thank you very much mr.
president and first let me say I would
like to thank Mitch McConnell for his
leadership and I'd also like to thank
Chuck Schumer for the enormous
bipartisan support we had on this bill
and the many senators both Republicans
and Democrats that work tirelessly over
the last five days on all the task force
the president said I got to live in the
LBJ room for the last five days and we
couldn't be more pleased
with the unprecedented response from the
Senate to protect American workers and
American business in this situation the
president has outlined many of these but
let me just quickly go through them
again small business retention loans
this will cover roughly 50% of the
private payroll in small businesses
where we will immediately make loans
that will supply eight weeks of salaries
as long as they keep workers employed
and overhead and those loans will be
forgiven at the end of the period as
long as they keep workers employed these
are SBA loans but the Treasury will be
issuing new regulations authorizing
almost every single FDIC insured bank to
make these I expect by the end of next
week we will have a very simple process
where these can be made and dispersed in
the same day so this will be a very
simple system to get money into small
business hands for companies that don't
qualify that we have a economic program
of tax incentives to retain workers and
as the president said we have enhanced
unemployment insurance for people don't
fit into these two programs that will be
administered through the states we also
have economic impact payments these will
be within the next three weeks direct
payments into most people's deposit
accounts and for those that don't have
it we will be having the the checks in
the mail our Treasury will have
additional authorities we have five
hundred billion dollars that we can use
to work with the Federal Reserve for
emergency programs that will create up
to an additional four trillion dollars
if needed to support American business
and American workers in an unprecedented
way and then finally the president
mentioned a hundred billion dollars to
hospitals and 150 billion dollars to
states that have specific coronavirus
expenses as well as many additional
things mr. president I especially want
to thank you and the vice president you
are constantly available
to us we spoke constantly throughout the
day you gave us guidance and quick
decisions on many issues and again thank
everybody for this great bipartisan work
this is going to be enormous help for
the American workers in the American
economy the president was very
determined that Congress would move
swiftly to protect hardworking Americans
in business in this unprecedented
situation thank you a great day day and
night that was there's a lot of work and
we'll see how it all goes we still need
a vote Steve don't really hand you have
a question yes you think this bill will
keep the economy afloat we have to go
back we have to go back we're gonna take
care of the American worker we're gonna
take care of these companies that fuel
this country and make the country great
it's not their fault it's not their
fault but we think hopefully
this war will be won quicker but we
expect that this is a significant amount
of money if needed to cover the economy
and don't forget a lot of this is going
to be to keep companies that are very
strong triple-a rated companies
previously to keep them going and it's
gonna be in the form of loan so the
money's gonna come back this money's got
a lot of this money's coming back
separately let me ask you about
something you said yesterday you said we
should never be reliant on a foreign
country for the means of our own
survived yeah what did you mean that
froze
well we're relying to many countries
where we give up our supply chains we
give up our factories we give up our
production facilities and we can buy at
someplace else for a little bit lower
price but it's really costing us more
when that happens because we lose jobs
we lose everything and we lose our
independence and we can't let that
happen so we'll be making some changes
we have been making those changes in
executive order to basically ban the
medical equipment I don't really will
need that but I think it's happening by
itself I think a lot of things are
happening well some people we make the
best medical equipment in the world and
you have some people like the European
Union they don't take it because they
have specifications that don't allow our
equipment in because it's designed in a
different way even though it's a better
way it's designed they're all they're
all playing games against us okay
they've been playing games against us
for years and no president has ever done
anything about it but the European Union
you look at medical equipment we make
the best medical equipment in the world
but we can't sell it because or not
appropriately and yet we take their
medical equipment in our country we're
changing things Steve all this is
changing but they have specifications so
that our equipment designed specifically
so that our equipment can't come into
their countries it's a very terrible
thing that's happened to our country and
let me tell you some of the people that
took the biggest advantage of us our
allies you know we talk about allies
they took advantage of us in many ways
but financially as well as even
militarily when you look at look I got
if you look at NATO the abuse that was
given to our country or NATO where they
wouldn't pay and we were paying for
everybody we're praying now because of
me they paint a lot now they paid a
hundred and twenty five hundred and
thirty five million billion dollars more
and then ultimately Secretary General
Stoltenberg well I think what you would
say is maybe my biggest fan we got him
to pay an additional four hundred
billion dollars billion other countries
and but but you know that and then
there's the trade they make it they make
it almost impossible for us to have a
fair deal they know this they know I'm
just waiting we have all the advantages
by the way it's going to be easy when I
decide to do it but this is the right
time to do it but we've been treated
very very unfairly by the European Union
mr. mr. president for Republican sinners
have indicated and the extra $600 for
unemployment insurance may encourage
workers to leave their jobs even though
you can only collect unemployment if
you're fired
I'm curious what you think of that
concern well I know the issue very well
we talked about it just a little while
ago
I'll let Steve like you may be discussed
there sure no the president I spoke to
several of those senators today but let
me just explain the issue which is we
wanted to have enhanced unemployment
insurance
most of these state systems have
technology that's 30 years old or older
so if we had the ability to customize
this with much more specifics we would
have this was the only way we could
assure that the states could get money
out quickly in a fair way so we used
$600 across the board and I I don't
think it'll create incentives most
Americans what they want they want to
keep their jobs and I said for 50% of
these these businesses they will have
the businesses keep those jobs so this
was in our number one issue was how do
we make sure that American workers who
needed to keep getting paid this is no
fault of their own that businesses have
been shut down the president and vice
president wanted to make sure those
hardworking Americans got money and this
was the most efficient way of doing it
she spoke with are they in agreement now
I'm not going to comment on the
specifics of where they are but I would
say you know our expectation is this
bill passes tonight and gets to the
house tomorrow and they pass it we need
to get this money into the American
economy and American workers that's the
the importance of this good thing when
you think about that people who to get
actually more money but we don't want to
give a disincentive but they have been
talking about that it's a good question
actually
yes ma'am please
thank you the family of another subject
the family of retired FBI agent Robert
Levinson says that US officials have
concluded that he's died in Iranian
custody were you aware of that and shiny
US officials yeah you know I've been
very much involved in that and he was a
great gentleman and a great family it's
just I mean I have to say this and
they've been making the statement to the
family I believe but it's not looking
good he wasn't well for years anyway in
Iran it's not looking promising we've
gotten so many people back we've got two
people back this week but Robert
Levinson who was outstanding he was he's
been sick for a long time and in it some
rough problems prior to his detainment
to a capture and we feel terribly for
the family but no I don't accept that
he's dead I don't accept it I mean I'm
telling you it's not it's not looking
great but I won't accept that he's dead
they haven't told us that he's dead but
a lot of people are thinking that that
is the case tweeted earlier linking the
closing of the country to your election
success in in November is this Easter
timeline based on your political
interest action success notes you said
that the media wants the country remain
closed to hurt your honor no the media
would like to see me do poorly in the
election I think I think
country by Easter is not a good idea
what is that plan based on just so you
understand are you ready I think there
are certain people that would like it
not to open so quickly I think there are
certain people that would like it to do
financially poorly because they think
that would be very good as far as
defeating me at the polls and I don't
know if that's so but I do think it's so
that a lot of that there are people in
your profession that would like that to
happen I think it's very clear I think
it's very clear that there are people in
your profession that write fake news you
do she does there are people in your
profession that write fake news they
would love to see me for whatever reason
because we've done one hell of a job
nobody's done the job that we've done
and it's lucky that you have this group
here right now for this problem or you
wouldn't even have a country left okay
we're hearing about pushing for April 6
I would say our expectation is within
three weeks we will have direct payments
out where we have depository information
and we're looking to get a lot more
information and we have procedures to do
that so three weeks for that and I would
say the end of next week we want all the
banks to be able to originate loans same
day Thank You mr. president
I have two questions for you one is this
that's more until at least
with the g20 leaders and I want to know
if you're gonna lead an effort to craft
a wolf-like ban on wild animal market
soon as to prevent another penned epic
given the mid-nineteen isn't zoonotic
that was transferred to humans in trade
to exotic cattle yeah I don't know that
that subjects going to come up there is
a lot of talk that that's how this all
happened came out of China and they say
that's how it happened in China so it's
something maybe we'll be talked about
but it's not the top of my list and also
a dr. Hershey Shah who is the head of
Harvard's Global Health Institute says
the key to getting this economy open as
soon as possible is to test everyone who
needs testing so we can quarantine all
infected individuals and allow everyone
else to go back to work immediately
would you subscribe to that strategy no
but I we have tested more than anybody I
saw and if not how many deaths are
acceptable yeah
how many none okay how many deaths are
acceptable to me and none okay none if
that's your question look I saw him I
saw his statement we have tested by far
more than anybody we're testing more
than anybody right now there's nobody
even close and our tests are the best
test they're the most accurate tests but
if you're saying we're going to test 350
million people I watched a statement I
disagree with it we can go to certain
states I could name them now but I'm not
gonna do that but we can go to certain
states right now they're virtually no
problem we're a very small problem we
don't have to test the entire state in
the middle west or wherever they may be
we'd have to test the entire state I
think it's ridiculous we don't have to
do it a lot of those states could go
back right now and they probably will
because at some point in the
not-too-distant future certain states
are gonna come off the rolls maybe New
York Kent and maybe California can't
maybe the state of Washington can't
although if you look at them their
biggest problem was in one nursing home
yeah go ahead but the states aren't
silent and
I mean somebody if you test one state
and then the person moves over to the
other state well then you're gonna just
look at that but if you take a look at
the states and many states that I'm
talking about they don't have a problem
we have some big problems but it's
confined to certain areas high density
areas so why would we test the entire
nation 350 people with that being said
I'm gonna say it again
we tested far more than anybody else we
are we have the ability to test
I mean we've come a long way from an
obsolete broken system that I inherited
we have now tested with the best test
far more than anybody else when I say
anybody else I'm talking about other
countries no country is even close they
came out with a statistic I guess
yesterday that I heard from dr. Burks
where it's four eight eight days here
more than eight weeks in South Korea and
South Korea done a good job but we did
in eight days more than South Korea did
in eight weeks that's a big number
and we're getting I said before
exponentially better every day is going
up substantially we have an incredible
apparatus built now but no I don't want
to test three hundred and fifty million
people I think it's ridiculous yes
please because there you ain't as the
g20 countries to do for more resources
for a coordinated stimulus package ban
on tariffs we've owned sanctions to try
to prevent what they call and
apocalyptic pandemic would you consider
those measures and with respect to what
tariffs and also related also to to wait
tariffs and also our strong
would you consider to join this global
effort so before I came here we weren't
into borders we had a country people
could come in we had a whole different
deal now we're up to almost a hundred
and sixty four miles think of that 164
miles of wall big beautiful wall and in
those areas it's very very tough to come
in we've been very tough on the borders
I mean where we have the wall built
nobody's getting through now they're
going around but that's a long trip if
they're going around that's the way they
get through but now I'm very strong and
borders and I don't want people coming
in here I what I want is if they're
gonna come and have to come in Legally
they have to come in through Merritt
we're not having the people that you're
talking about coming to our country all
right question for you then for me both
Republican and Democrat packages of the
stimulus included 25 million dollars
worth of funding for the Kennedy
performance arts center here in
Washington DC shouldn't that money be
going to masks respirators no what I
approve that and I knew it was 35
million and we actually took off ten but
I'm a fan of that although I haven't
spent time there because I'm far too
busy I'd love to go there evenings but
I'm too busy doing things because that's
more important for me than going there
but the Kennedy Center has suffered
greatly because nobody can go there it's
essentially closed and they do need some
funding and I said look that was a
Democrat request that was not my request
but you got to give him something it's
something that they wanted you know it
works that way where the Democrats have
treated us fairly I really believe that
we've had a very good back-and-forth and
I say that with respect to Chuck Schumer
I spoke to him a number of times but you
know they had requests also so that was
a request there were 35 yes you know and
it came down to 25 we got it down to 25
we agreed I said that's a lousy two
soundbite that's not a good sound bite
but that's the way life works with that
being said the Kennedy Center they do a
beautiful job an incredible job David
Rubenstein too
a fantastic job he's very much involved
and he puts up a lot of money and he
does things that a lot of people
wouldn't be able to do or do but they've
been essentially closed they have
tremendous deficits that are built up I
mean this thing has been devastating to
it so I didn't have a big problem with
it but this was a request from the
Democrats because of the fact that they
have a facility that's essentially
closed up another question serve I
wanted to go there tonight to look at
Romeo and Juliet I'd love to see Romeo
and Juliet tonight
sorry 250 people or 50 people whatever
it might be down to good and then
earlier today Senator Marco Rubio told
RCP that quote the World Health
Organization showed favoritism to China
on flow and then representative Michael
McCaul the ranking member on the the
House Foreign Relations Committee he
questioned the integrity of the World
Health Organization's director saying
quote that there were several red flags
in his past with respect to his
relationship with China do you agree do
you think the World Health Organization
showed favoritism and then once all the
dust settles do you think that the
United States should reexpose
relationship with the World Health
Organization I think there is a lot of
certainly a lot of talk that has been
very unfair I think that a lot of people
feel that it's been very unfair it's
been very very much sided with China and
a lot of people are not happy about it
at the same time doctor foul chair
myself and other people there are people
on there that we like and we know a lot
of I think your friends are there a lot
of good people a lot of good
professionals I don't know be
interesting to hear if you'd like to
talk about the world WHL but the fact is
that I have heard for years that that is
very much biased toward China so I don't
know
you want me to get you into this
political message no I don't want you to
do that but I will so Ted Rose is really
an outstanding person I've known him
from the time that he was the Minister
of Health of Ethiopia I mean obviously
over the years anyone who says that the
w-h-o has not had problems has not been
watching the w-h-o but I think under his
leadership they've done very well he has
been all over this I was on
the phone with him a few hours ago
leading a wh Oh call Caesar no I'm not
true I'm not talking about China you
asked me about Ted Rose will help
organization praising China for its
transparency and leadership on their
response the pandemic you know I I can't
comment on that because I mean that I
don't have any viewpoint into it I mean
I don't I don't even know what your
question is let me just tell you I have
heard that for years I spoke to him
yesterday seems fine to me I don't know
but we're the ones who gave the great
response and we're the ones that kept
China out of here and if we didn't do it
you'd have thousands and thousands of
people died would have died that are now
living and happy if I didn't do that
early call on China and nobody wanted
that to happen everybody thought it was
a just unnecessary to do it and if we
didn't do that thousands and thousands
of people would have died more than
what's happened so that's it right maybe
one more Steve guy when you have this
g20 meeting tomorrow what sort of
coordinated response are you expecting
we have a meeting with the 20 nations
total including us and there'll be it'll
be a conference call tomorrow morning
sometime I look forward to people I know
I like I think in every instance I like
every one of them but it'll be an
interesting call you'll be the first to
know next week when the 15 day period
ends what should we expect that are you
gonna extend it for another what are you
talking about I'll be speaking I'll be
speaking with Tony I'll be speaking with
Deborah be speaking with some of the
people that they like and respect and
they're gonna bring along with them
we'll be speaking to Vice President Mike
Pence and Steve and we'll be speaking to
everybody I'm not going to do anything
rash or hastily I don't do that but the
country wants to get back to work our
country was built to get back to work we
don't have the country where they say
hey let's close it down for two years we
can't do that it's not our country so
we're gonna be talking and it could be
will do sections of our country there's
big sections of our country that are
very you know little affected by what's
taking place then there are other sex
very heavily affected so there's a big
difference but no I would say by Easter
we'll have a recommendation and maybe
before Easter and at the end of the
fifteenth day or even during the
fifteenth day I think we'll have some
kind of a recommendation but our country
wants to get back to work Steve I have
had so many people and they want to
practice social distancing and they want
to practice no hand shaking no hand
shaking
they're not going to walk around hugging
and kissing each other in the office
where they come back even though they
may feel like it they're gonna do
they're gonna wash their hands more than
they've ever done they're gonna do all
the things you're supposed to do but
Steve you know what it's it's time they
want people want to get back to work I'm
having I get you know I get it from both
sides in all fairness and maybe it's a
combination of both Tony said before
combination of both is sometimes very
good but there are areas that possibly
probably they won't qualify there are
other areas that qualify almost now so
we're gonna have to see what happens but
it'll be an interesting period of time
I'd like to get our country back I have
tremendous numbers of people wanting to
go back you have store owners where the
store is sitting there they don't know
what's happened they got to get back
your businesses that are going to be
closed the longer we stay out the longer
we do it we want to go quickly to longer
we stay out the harder it is to bring
this incredible we were having the most
successful years that we've ever had in
the history of our country you saw what
happened yesterday with the stocks and
today they're up I'm telling you if
Steve gets the deal done the incredible
incentive just going to take care of
people it's gonna take care of our
workers gonna take care of companies
that employ all these workers small and
big by the way I would say we spend more
time on the small company Steve that we
get in the big companies you know people
ask about that we spent more time
thinking about the small businesses than
the big and that's but you know that
really fuels our country we want to get
back and the people want to get back we
want to get our country going again and
we'll be able to do that so vice
president's going to stay with you and
gonna take a few more questions
specifically
and I will see you tomorrow thank you
very much well thank you all report on
today's action by the White House
coronavirus task force the president and
our entire team continue to be inspired
by the way people all across this
country we're putting into practice 15
days to slow the spread we are 10 days
into the 15 days and let me say again to
every American if you're in an area
that's been impacted by the coronavirus
it's absolutely essential that you
listen to state and local authorities
for guidance but for every American what
you can do is implement the practices
outlined in the president's coronavirus
guidelines today because we truly do
believe that as millions of Americans
have done and will continue to do that
we can significantly impact the the rate
of growth in this epidemic in our
country we can spare Americans from
exposure to the corona virus and we can
save lives and so on behalf of the
President and our entire task force I
want to say thank you to the American
people thank you for your cooperation
thank you for embracing the principles
in 15 days to slow the spread we heard
about that cooperation today in a series
of conference calls
we spoke with equipment manufacturers
who are stepping forward as as never
before to assist us in developing the
medical equipment that is essential
whether it be masks or other medical
supplies or ventilators FEMA reported to
our task force today that hundreds of
companies have stepped forward to be
involved in the supply chain and we are
we are vetting nearly 70 of those
countries for specific repurposing of
their manufacturing to produce
everything from mast
to gowns and of course to ventilators we
also had a very productive call with
secretary Betsy DeVos with education
leaders from around the country today
and let me say on behalf of the
President and a grateful nation thank
you to all of our teachers many of whom
are now home teaching children from afar
even in many cases while they have their
own kids home from school you are truly
heroes and the Department of Education
as well as your State Department of
Education are grateful to each and every
one of you who find yourselves educating
out-of-home and the Department of
Education has a helpful website on
coronavirus recommendations Edie govt /
corona virus and as we mentioned before
secretary Betsy DeVos and secretary
sonny perdue will be joining us at this
podium on friday to speak about distance
learning recommendations that have been
made not just for secondary or for
college education but also for K through
12 education we're opening up avenues
creating new flexibility so that not
only college students can continue to be
involved in learning from afar but
children K through 12 can do the same
secretary
Purdue will also be here to talk about
the food lunch program and free and
reduced lunches today the president and
I also spoke to over 150 CEOs of the top
nonprofit organizations in the country
we thanked them for their ongoing work
supplying the needs not only of people
impacted by the corona virus but the
most vulnerable among us in our
communities organizations like Red Cross
the Salvation Army feeding America are
all still working every day and we
promise to urge every American if you
have the means and have the ability
continue to be generous to nonprofit
organizations that are helping those
most in need in your community the
president marshaled a
whole-of-government approach that means
working with our governor's today and
the president I were in direct contact
with
of New York California Washington State
New Jersey Michigan and others and we
continue to be inspired and impressed by
the leadership that governor's are
providing in their states making tough
choices leading their states and the
president and I are truly grateful the
task force made a recommendation and
FEMA has assembled a team for to provide
technical assistance to the state of New
York and that team was welcomed by
Governor Cuomo will be arriving on the
ground there very soon along with all
the other resources that the president
recently announced would be flowing to
New York and to Washington State and to
California in my conversation with
governor Gavin Newsom of California I
was pleased to speak to him and hear
that our FEMA team is literally at the
table with the State of California's
team working to meet their supply needs
working to work on capacity and I want
people to know in the states that are
most impacted by the corona virus that
we are with you and we're going to stay
with you we're going to continue to work
around the clock to make sure your
courageous health care workers your
health systems and your state
governments have the resources to
support your response on the subject of
testing dr. Burks will reflect on what
the data is showing in just a moment and
not including local labs and hospitals
we are at four hundred and thirty-two
thousand tests completed and we're
pleased to see that they're literally
drive-through in community sites around
the country and the US public health
services assisting States in standing
those up each and every day we do remind
hospitals and labs around the country
and the moment the president signs the
bill that it that it is absolutely
essential that they provide the results
of the tests to us it gives us
visibility into what's happening on the
ground but because of the public-private
partnership president Trump initiated
with these vast commercial lab networks
around the country we are adding tens of
thousands of tests every single day on
the subject of supplies before the end
of the week
talk a bit more as the President did
moments ago about the supply chain I was
at FEMA last night
and literally saw a room full of people
with laptops and cell phones we are
literally leaving no stone unturned as I
told governor's today to find medical
supplies whether it be whether it be a
mask or gowns or gloves or ventilators
and the team is working around the clock
to meet those needs a few smaller items
first and foremost the CDC is developing
guidance which we'll be publishing
tomorrow about the best way to utilize
our natural resources at our parks it
would be several weeks ago that our Park
Service waived all entrance fees and
we've directed the CDC to produce
guidance for how people can still
practice social distancing and common
sense but be out of doors and enjoy our
natural parks we'll also be sharing that
guidance with the vast state park
systems around the country and
encouraging their support with that let
me let me last say again there is
nothing more important for the American
people to do to slow the spread than to
heed your state and local guidance in
areas impacted by the coronavirus and
for everyone else to put into practice
the 15 days to slow the spread
dr. Fauci will reflect on the importance
of mitigation and the impact that we
believe that it is having around the
country but it is the people ask me
time-to-time what can I do and I say
from my heart to every American this is
what you can do not just to protect your
own health and that of your family but
no American wants to inadvertently
spread the coronavirus particularly to
those that may be vulnerable to serious
health consequences remember that the
risk of serious illness to the average
American remains low I mean the vast
majority of people that contract the
coronavirus will have mild symptoms -
flu-like symptoms
and and and will recover but for seniors
with serious underlying health
conditions or with people with
immunodeficiencies everyone needs to
practice the principles of 15 days to
slow the spread the president announced
this week that we are looking forward to
the day that we can open up the country
and this team will be bringing in
recommendations about how we can safely
and responsibly do just that but for
every American that wants to see America
back in business
you can hasten the day by putting into
practice the 15 days to slow the spread
go to coronavirus cotton gov for details
and I truly do believe if all of us will
do all that we can do we will slow the
spread we will protect the most multiple
and we will heal our land with that let
me recognize dr. Tony Fauci and speak
about dr. Burks please Thank You mr.
vice president
and thank you all for listening to us
talk to the American people we've been
watching the testing results very oh
it's very critical to us it's very
critical to be looking at that very
carefully let me tell you two things
that are going on in parallel our system
to look at flu-like illnesses is still
up and running and in County after
County and state after state and why is
that important for those who've been
following the flu epidemic this year
you'll remember we had flu a then we had
another peak of flu B and those systems
that are in every single state and local
government is the platform where we can
see whether there's any increase in
flu-like illnesses so if you have very
few cases in your state and in your
counties maintain your flu surveillance
system that you work closely with the
CDC on and look for changes in your
slope of new flu light illnesses and
there are enough test kits and there's
particularly enough of the CDC test kit
where we started that runs on your flu
surveillance platform to be constantly
surveilling what those flu-like
illnesses are in our states and counties
that have very low number of cases we
have counties still with zero to one
case
but they can participate in their
surveillance that we need to have out
there now by using their flu-like
surveillance system and we thank all of
the states who have that up and running
if you go to CDC gov and go to flu
surveillance you can see state by state
and you can be looking at those curves
with us it's what we're looking at day
by day in addition to the testing
results that are coming in for the
testing results still there's four
counties that constitute the majority of
both the current cases and new cases I
think you know those are New York City
Westchester New York Suffolk's and
Nassau County those are the four
counties all associated with New York in
the New York metro area there's a few
counties in New Jersey but this is still
where 56% of the cases are and 56% of
the new cases it's very important that
people look at the number of new cases
per day remember we told you was going
to take us a while to work through the
testing backlog I think we are close to
working through the testing backlog so
that you can interpret the number of
cases per day and you will see in New
York City that the number of cases per
day has been relatively constant over
the last three days those are the number
of new cases per day this is a real call
to every person in New York City in the
New York metro area to continue every
one of these 15 days to slow the spread
and to do that part of it at the same
time that they're following the mayors
and governors piece yesterday we talked
about people that it may have left the
metro area that were residents residents
of the metro area that may have gone to
secondary homes or other places went to
her side and we've asked all of them to
carefully monitor their temperatures and
self isolate from the communities where
they went just to ensure their own
health and the health of their
communities while they people move
around the country finally why this is
so important it's very important to me
personally because my grandmother for 88
years lid with the fact that she was the
one at age 11 who brought home flu to
her
mother named Lea for which I am named
when her mother had just delivered and
her mother was succumbed to the great
1918 flu she never forgot that she was
the child that was in school that
innocently blot that flu home this is
why we keep saying to every American you
have a role to protect each and every
person that you interact with we have a
role to protect one another it's why we
are social distancing and your social
distancing but to every American out
there when you are protecting yourself
you're protecting others and if you
inadvertently
I know brought this virus home to
someone with a pre-existing condition I
can tell you my grandmother lived with
that for 88 years so this is what we're
trying this is the message that's
important to everybody this is not a
theoretic this is a reality you can see
the number of deaths that are occurring
we all have a role in preventing them so
thank you for the work that you do to
get our message out to others to really
ensure that every American understands
how important their role is as we move
through these next five days to not let
up for an instant I hear some reports
that someone said oh oh the new cases in
New York are increasing or the
hospitalizations are increasing the
number of new cases over the last three
days have been consistent but not rising
any more than a consistent day over day
rise you will see hospital cases
continue to increase because they are
reflection of what happened one to two
weeks ago before the full mitigation
efforts were put into place
so each person in every place no matter
what County what community which state
can work with us to ensure that we
prevent the spread of this virus to
others so thank you
Thank You mr. vice president I just want
to spend a couple of minutes telling you
a little bit about some information that
I got on our weekly call that we have at
least once a week with the W WH o which
is led by dr. Ted Rose and Mike Ryan
who's the point man there to give us
some information and
that regard I want to apologize for my
current response to you when you asked
me about the China deal because I
shouldn't have done that that's not my
style but what I really wanted to say is
that my job is that I'm a scientist I'm
a physician and I'm a public health
person and I don't like to get involved
and that stuff so anyway getting back to
the w-h-o so we learned some really
interesting information because
obviously the other countries like China
and others have had been hit prior that
we did one of the things that was
striking to me and I just throw it out
because it's something that we will face
we're not facing it now but we will face
our Chinese colleagues are very
concerned because they went through the
entire cycle of the curve to come down
they have very very few cases but what
they're starting to see as they're
relaxing the constraints on travel that
they're getting imported cases and they
wanted to warn us that when we get
successful make sure you very carefully
examine how you're going to release the
constraints on input so I know we're
gonna be successful in putting this
under control but I think we're gonna
have to remember we don't want to import
cases in that's the first thing for
today the second thing that was
important is that it was something that
dr. Burks mentioned and that is when you
look at the inflection of the curves we
now have multiple different countries
that have gone through various phases of
their individual outbreaks and you can
learn something from them about where
you are in your own outbreak for example
when China went up what happened is they
just didn't turn around
they went from going to I'll just take
an arbitrary number 500 new cases a day
the next day it was a thousand cases
than 1500 and then 2,000 but once the
number of new cases each day starts to
flatten out that's when you get to that
point where the inflection goes down so
if you what things we want to look for
the things that dr. Burks had mentioned
that doesn't mean you declare victory
when it does that but you know you're at
least
on the way to where you want to go and I
think that's really very important the
third and final thing that I think gets
back to the question that many of you in
the audience have asked of us is about
would this possibly become a seasonal
cyclic thing and I've always indicated
to you that I think it very well might
and the reason I say that is that what
we're starting to see now in the
southern hemisphere in southern Africa
and in the southern hemisphere countries
is that we're having cases that are
appearing as they go into their winter
season and if in fact they have a
substantial outbreak it will be
inevitable that we need to be prepared
that we'll get a cycle around the second
time what does that mean for us in what
we're doing
it totally emphasizes the need to do
what we're doing in developing a vaccine
testing it quickly and trying to get it
ready so they will have a vaccine
available for that next cycle in
addition to do the randomized controlled
trials of drugs so that we will have a
menu of drugs that we have shown to be
effective and shown to be safe because I
know we'll be successful in putting this
down now but we really need to be
prepared for another cycle and what
we're doing I believe will prepare us
well thank you they suggested that
there's only 16,000 in the national
stockpile can you just give us some
clarity how many ventilators do you have
the national stockpile
who else is making them and how long
will it take for them to make
clematis based on the Center for Public
Integrity it appears there aren't enough
if you were going to die there's all the
ventilators is eveni a singular focus of
a good portion of our supply chain
stabilisation task force at FEMA since
the president stood up FEMA's National
Response Center and we're making
progress in a variety of ways first
there there is the national stockpile
which you refer and depending on what's
been distributed we just delivered four
thousand ventilators to New York
including ventilators that we sent to
New York City but there's that that
number of some some twenty thousand less
than 20,000 I won't dispute your number
beyond that there literally are by most
estimates more than a hundred and fifty
thousand ventilators in the broad
healthcare system all across the country
we also working with anesthesiologists
and there was a very important
conference call today we have determined
several weeks ago that the devices that
anesthesiologists used for outpatient
surgery can be converted with the change
of a single vent to a very useful
ventilator I actually spoke to Governor
Cuomo about that today he's in the
process of surveying all of his surgical
centers as governor's around the country
are doing we literally believe there's
tens of thousands of ventilators that
can be converted now that the FDA has
given guidance and dr. Burks can
probably speak to that in a moment we
actually have produced a helpful video
to explain how quickly those devices can
be converted but we're also working with
General Motors and and other companies
to immediately spin up production those
contracts are being reviewed we're
vetting their capability but one of the
other ideas as we look at areas of the
country that are most impacted and now
more than half of the cases for
coronavirus are in New York State and in
the region around there but we'll focus
we'll want to focus our resources
including ventilators
on where where communities are
struggling the most with coronavirus and
so one of the ways that we're working
through that at FEMA now is by spinning
up production and at the same time
working with the existing national
supply maybe from areas that don't have
a particular burden yet with the
coronavirus and making sure that we're
manufacturing back filling and meeting
that need but what I can tell you is
we've got an extraordinary team
Admiral pelagic is a two-star Navy
admiral who's doing an incredible job we
literally are Dennis identifying
resources around the country and around
the world we're contracting and
arranging transportation for those but
maybe maybe dr. Burks you can speak to
those so I just want to thank dr. Mary
Peterson and the whole team of the
American Association of anesthesiologist
because they immediately when we asked
them could these be modified they went
to mediate work on it they've done
they're gonna have Q&A ZUP for but more
importantly every anesthesiologist in
every city has been working with their
state and local health officials to
really work with them how to change this
and I think it's not only the
ventilators that they'll be supplying
they have the people that run those
ventilators that are not any longer
doing elective surgery so changing that
electrics elective surgery piece over a
week ago has freed up a lot of
additional resources when I talk to you
about how we are we've done some things
that are very horizontal across the
country but we're collecting data now in
a county by county granular way so it's
like any epidemic it's not equal
everywhere there are places that are
very spared and there's paces where
there's more we have a very vast country
with a lot of capacity and a lot of
infrastructure and so looking very
specifically about where the virus has
been where is it going
who's got freed up resources from where
it has been because it didn't hit all it
hit a Washington state earlier than it
hit New York and looking at all of those
pieces to really ensure
how we can innovatively move equipment
around based on the need
and so I know that it has become a place
where people are looking at numbers
rather than what is needed because if
you do these projections when you got to
those projections that said like in
Germany and others that have implied
that sixty percent or fifty percent of
the population would get infected the I
want to be very clear the only way that
happens is is this virus remains
continuously moving through populations
in this cycle in the fall cycle and
another cycle so that's through three
cycles with nothing being done and so
we're dealing with the cycle a right now
not the one that could come in the fall
of 2020 are though we're getting
prepared for it by the innovations that
are being worked on and not the twenty
twenty one we're really dealing with the
here and now why we're planning for the
future and I think the numbers that have
been put out there are actually very
frightening to people but I can tell you
if you go back and look at Wuhan and who
Bay and all of these provinces when they
talk about sixty thousand people being
infected even if you said oh right well
there's asymptomatic sand all of that so
you get to six hundred thousand people
out of eighty million that is nowhere
close to the numbers that you see people
putting out there I think it is
frightened the American people I think
on a freely on a model that you just run
full out you can get to those numbers if
you have zero controls and you do
nothing and we know that every American
is doing something and so I think what
our job right now is is to carefully
detail on a hospital by hospital state
by state county by county to outline
what the infrastructure needs are and
ensure that we're meeting them both from
the stockpile and from the generosity
and movement of the American people and
other hospitals a lot of folks out there
well-intentioned are sewing cloth masks
and don't
the hospital senior dr. pouchy can you
weigh in on that because obviously these
people have great intentions but there's
some mixed feedback on whether that's a
good idea
so clothing manufacturers volunteers
dropping them off in hospitals is that
necessary is that helpful is it
something you'd recommend well you would
only recommend that on the desperate
situations if you don't have any masks
but what we're seeing now is as you've
heard is a rather significant inflow of
masks that are coming in that are gonna
be available I mean obviously if you
don't have a mask and you need a mask
and it's appropriate for you to be aware
it you do what you can but I don't see
that now as a necessity giving what's
going on right now states that are
trying to buy this necessary equipment
onto a private market and the governor
of Kentucky said yesterday that his
state was in line to buy some equipment
but FEMA came in and bought it purchased
it from under them so he says this is
creating a real problem but space
because on the one hand they're being
repelled to get the equipment themselves
if they can but on the other hand the
federal government is buying up the
supply chain so is this a problem that
you're hearing about and what is your
advice to states like Kentucky we're
having this issue I actually spoke to
the governor of Michigan today governor
Whitmer and I about just that and we put
our our FEMA regional representative
right on the case we want to make sure
that we are what we're acquiring every
bit as much as we can through FEMA but
as we've worked with the supply chain we
want to have full coordination with the
states and of course they're making in
hospitals that they're making and and
we're looking into those matters but
make no mistake about it this FEMA team
at the president's Direction is leaning
into this effort leaving no stone
unturned literally searching not just
the nation but the world for all these
critical supplies and as the president
just reported to you we're in the
process of shipping 9.4
million in 95 respirators 20 million
surgical masks 3.1 million face shields
and the list goes on and we're gonna be
shipping those every single day but as I
told a governor Whitmer today who's
leading her state through all of this
with great energy we want to partner
with her we want to partner with every
governor and make sure that the left
hand knows what the right hand is doing
in terms of acquiring resources on the
ground so report that their mask
shortages when with timelines for making
sure everyone well I'm gonna let dr.
Burke's address that as well but let me
say again I just received a report we're
gonna be detailing it before the end of
the week where we might we've literally
identified significant resources not
just around the country but around the
world of the mass that can be used by
healthcare workers and but as dr. Burke
said we are focusing those resources in
the areas where health care workers are
most exposed to the prospect of
contracting and the coronavirus
president's made it clear from early on
right after seeing in the needs of
Americans who are struggling with the
coronavirus making sure they have the
support that they need on the same level
of priority we want our health care
workers to have the personal protective
equipment to be able to do their job
safely and we're working on that I will
tell you I spoke about this today to
several governor's not only the governor
of Michigan but the governor of Indiana
and president Trump and I couldn't be
more grateful the way governor's around
the country are joining us in calling on
businesses to go back to their
warehouses and identify industrial masks
n95 masks that because of the change
that President Trump insisted on in the
law
can now be used by hospital workers and
their their perfectly acceptable to
protect a healthcare worker from the
possibility of a respiratory disease but
we're calling on and our governors are
joining us in calling on every business
across America during this time of great
challenge where many businesses are
idled go back to your storehouses
identify n95 industrial masks and as I
told our governor's today they can call
FEMA they can call the state the state
healthcare services or they can just
load them up on a flatbed and drive them
over to their local hospital and
literally we hear stories in every state
in the Union of people doing that and so
it's it's happening all at the same time
and we'll be detailing the progress
we're making on masks anything further I
just wanted to add one piece and this is
really a call to every state out there
in every County that has been doing
community-based testing the FDA put out
new guidance we talked about it several
days ago that people can do self testing
in the drive-through where you give them
the materials to do it in their car and
you pick it up in a biohazard bag this
would free up all of that PPE that you
see being utilized in those drive
throughs back to the hospitals and back
to the clinics that need it the most we
have to move to the new technology
whipped FDA worked tirelessly to get
that out there so that it could be
sparing of gowns and gloves and full
mess respiratory and 95s this is the
moment to move to that self testing
front of nose with the new applicators
that can be utilized so that every
single bit of the n95 s can be put into
the hospitals that need it let me just
say we look forward to seeing you all
tomorrow we'll be back here with further
progress and news but if I could just
say to every American
we'll get through this we'll get through
this but we'll get through this together
every American needs to understand that
whether you are in an area that's
impacted by the coronavirus or an area
where there's very few cases if you do
your part to put into practice 15 days
to slow the spread you will do just that
you'll love you'll impact the spread of
this coronavirus epidemic in our country
these experts tell me that we can
significantly reduce the number of
Americans that would be exposed to the
corona virus as every American continues
to put these guidelines into practice
and we just know that with all of the
extraordinary effort that's being done
at the federal level by this tremendous
team and all of our agencies all the
great leadership by governor's in both
parties across the country with all the
incredible and courageous work by health
care workers with the cooperation and
the prayers of the American people we
will get this done we will we will not
only we will not only slow the spread
would protect the vulnerable and will
heal our land thank you
[Music]